welcome to this video playing Nikhil
again I played him just just briefly
flame just a couple of days ago and
games ago what is the same thing
actually I don't know I had a game like
this maybe maybe is playing the same
okay it's playing the same line it's not
good it hasn't improved let's say since
since last time okay yeah I'm really
just the porn up he can take you for
though getting the palm back but it's
still a very good good version of of
this no nerve known line
yeah cannot take on d Hall because of
the pinning business okay really is this
so dangerous night except maybe it is
it's something to to attend to probably
maybe just get the Queen back yeah but
now the snide c7 is not not a big
problem isn't it it's not really having
any any great squares to go to um I can
even consider I can also start with rock
yet all 95 is also possible or this sir
this is actually good intending we
should be seven with the temple 97's
really not a move well maybe not so used
to the structure why this is just just
journey with no return ticket where are
you going with this night and leukoc 8
and hmm I can go to be five is there
anything better even to to discourage
that group d 8 maybe setting up a pin
it's maybe even better
and turn yeah this looks really strange
all this is hanging this is hanging out
so have 95 night before him okay that's
that's at least good for black I mean
maybe it's not the best but it's it's
good any evening wait I also Bishop a
six but then F 4 p.m. this is ok night a
seven I always have Quincy five check
I'm just stunned that this is so this is
play diem can go give this chick and go
Quinn to a forum
I'm coin a form it does not seem that
he's losing the night out right may I go
now still not be five quite remarkable
does not seem to be a direct refutation
of this as weird as it looks maybe this
this check and shove a six check I don't
I don't see a direct reputation probably
I'm just totally blind because it seems
really weird that this should work time
morning oh maybe just got c4 coming you
I can do something like this sir but
it's not convincing really remarkable
really but you could take on a seven
why I don't know down to 37 seconds
because I was trying to refute this
strange play and it didn't really didn't
really succeed we should maybe seven I
cannot really think it's possible yeah I
cannot I cannot play for our foreign
front end game anymore this is not a
good idea with little time okay but I'm
winning now made on h2 taking on age 7
was just just a very strange decision
yeah 25 seconds check now my rook is not
really playing at the moment no it is
that's a good news it should be 72 okay
just giving away another another piece
check
yeah just promoting him check check
indeed the second Queen check check
check check mate cool yeah this was
really one of the most cheekiest place
that I've seen for a while 97 and 97 I
mean this is really banking on on the
fact that I'm sometimes just to really
did I mean I must be totally winning
here and i am with night h5 I didn't see
that night age five assists Fred Fred
winning now yes no he has no square for
the for the for the bishop check this is
directly losing gallant knight aight i
can take a phone take a 8 next with the
win okay but this is still good until
the taking on a sadness really really
remarkable but it seems to be seems to
be working only there is no direct win
the computer also doesn't find one check
no there's there's no way to to to use
the the default situation the pins
remarkable
okay yeah I could have taken CP and
queen d 4 with a good position mmm yeah
I didn't have much time taking work T 2
but yeah i know but i need to need to
keep the chance on this is weird why
would you spend a whole move for that
it's probably ok but need to be very
cautious now Bishop d3 however saving
the day this is however losing yeah I'm
a queen up yeah I have a night h-hi it
was a really bad miss I mean 97 was a
really strange decision as it's clear
that this is a totally alone warrior you
know you're not going to win anything
with the night so this snide h5 was very
clear and here there's probably still
something like that yeah this is peace
has no square really it hasn't something
like this it's not wrong all this
they're very close to checkmates yeah if
he goes check checkmate at this made
coming this is a typical idea with the
bishop on c5 yeah very lucky win at the
end for me that he blundered this room
looked into thing ok thanks for watching